là où ça bouge ce soir vous allez
découvrir une nouvelle salle de
spectacle et ensuite nous irons voir les
riff raff qui fêtent leurs 10 ans avec
un tribute demain pour qui aura commencé
avec les riff raff ça fait deux fois
battu cette semaine que vous faites ça
là où ça bouge nous sommes avec riff
raff on vous en a déjà parlé c'est un
groupe qui adore les beatles
aulas
comme au squash comment vous faites pour
obtenir ce soutien prend le débit et tu
travailles de vente à glace timide tu
fais ça toute la journée pendant des
mois et peut-être un jour qui réussira à
les imiter mais c'est très difficile
c'est vraiment du travail sur la voix
sur des instruments oui oui il faut
rendre hommage à ce groupe parce que ils
sont tellement connu tu peux pas faire
semblant
est-ce qu'il ya plusieurs groupes qui
imite ou qui font du jeu pensez y si
d'ici c'est l'un des groupes les plus
reprises au monde oui mais vous avez le
pen avait déjà rencontré des groupes
comme vous qui faisait de lui s'il dit
oui on en a massacré
le tribute festival c'est la septième
édition et il y aura jimi hendrix sur
scène il y aura motörhead
pink floyd
et évidemment et si d'ici c'est à dire
qu'on recrée une affiche complètement
impossible de nos jours le trio de
permet ça
non
dimanche à 17 heures au théâtre de caen
une pièce de circonstance qui s'appelle
les cartes du pouvoir ou les
présidentielles j'ai besoin des
meilleurs il fait un tout droit sans
mais parce que tu as pièces inspirées
les marches du pouvoir qui me réalisé
par george clooney une pièce avec
notamment thierry frémont entré chez eux
ils ont brassé leurs femmes et leurs
marc frémond il ose le square avec
patrick raffour marseille mercredi au
théâtre des cordes de caen et de sdf sur
un truc pareil et que ce type pouvait
remercier dieu qu'il était miraculé ils
ont tracté à sa santé et ils sont allés
se coucher 270 places dans cette
nouvelle salle
on ne vous dit pas encore où elle se
trouve marie blanche va nous donner
d'ores et déjà la programmation pour
vous faire une petite idée
alors alors une programmation riche et
diversifiée dans ce théâtre on
accueillera les marins du cotentin donc
un spectacle de chant
une one woman show en février également
dès lors c'est deauville on prend une
tournure parce que on avait fait un long
portrait d'elle notamment dans la manche
peut aussi à paris c'est une formidable
comédienne d'autres spectacles dans le
cadre de l'opération ville en scène du
théâtre et encore du théâtre du cinéma
des spectacles pour les enfants
également
alors cette salle a été créé en quelle
année c'est une toute nouvelle salle
inaugurée en jeu en juin 2015 qu'est ce
que veut ici avant un théâtre mais il a
été totalement restauré totalement c'est
sûr j'ai envie d'un petit souci au début
j'étais un petit peu oui effectivement
il y avait un petit souci entre les
sièges pas assez d'espacé tout ça était
renouvelé enfin là là là c'est parfait
oui eh bien non
regardez moi je suis gros j'arrive à
mettre très très bien quelle est leur
ambassade alors le théâtre des halles
combien d'habitants dans cette veine
1500 habitants parce que vous avez une
petite idée nous sommes dans la manche
on peut le dire
allez on va révéler long de la commune
nous sommes à tes c'est sûr bien sachez
que ce soir sur cette belle scène du
théâtre des halles de tessy-sur-vire le
claveciniste américain kenneth weiss
sera là accompagné de l'orchestré
régional de normandie qui est en deuil
ce soir puisque hier soir dans la nuit
et bien thierry tisserand inde et
violoniste de l'orchestré régional nous
a quittés évidemment ceux là où ça bouge
lui est totalement dédiée